good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday that was really
[ __ ] good everybody's looking forward
to the merch launch merch shop it's
Friday it is our winter Mertz drop day
1:00 p.m. Eastern Time is when
everything is going live on shop morning
toast calm we're gonna start off today's
episode talking about merch I heard you
guys have some questions like sizing
questions I was taking some questions on
my Instagram last night I got some great
questions people were asking what sizes
you wear for certain items so obviously
as you know we did a whole extra as hell
photo shoot shoot for our holiday photos
and now we just like have these cute
photos of ourselves but like when we
were taking them we were like we are
never going to use these photos I felt
so fat like being shot in natural
lighting is a very brave thing to do oh
no for me it's natural lighting or bus
no my god I like a warm studio light
with like a with a yellow undertone Oh
for me it makes me look like a person
that I'm not I love like a big window
lit thing but the pictures came out so
cute so cute
so like warm and Utah Sun and they're
very winter and they really highlight
this collection that we love we're
wearing some of our favorite items today
but no one ever gets to choose our
favorites if you're watching on YouTube
feel free to drop a question about um
submerge whether it's just sizing or
shipping it or anything I am wearing the
new cropped black hoodie I'm wearing it
in a size extra large because the large
fit me but I'm just like not the type of
girl who like wears a crop sweater that
much so I sized up so it would be like a
little bit longer this one goes like
almost to my hips like below my belly
you want to stand in maybe shower
sure and normally I wouldn't really wear
a cropped sweatshirt but because these
pants hide my Fupa so well I think it's
a really cute look I'm wearing a large
in the pants they fit very nice they
have an elastic waistband and a
drawstring which we love and they have a
pocket in the back two pockets on the
sides oh my god like when we were in
Utah ward this this is why I wear this
today because I wore it the most in you
tell like when I had the whole
collection what did I actually wear and
I wore this the most and now I'm wearing
it I'm gonna kinda go right after this
and I'm wearing it all weekend I'll be
traveling and it's literally the only
thing I packed
it's so cute I actually I usually size
up in everything that I wear but for
that I
I wore a small sweatshirt and a small
pant because I think that their I hate
to say that something runs bigger run
small cuz I just feel like I've run big
and small yeah I don't want to speak to
something else cuz like I actually don't
know I'm just like I'm gonna cry
according to WHO I'm just a weird size
so I guess technically they would run
big if I'm wearing a small I am wearing
this toasty Christmas lights holiday
sweatshirt this is a size large and it
just about fits me as a dress I wear
that in an Excel to fit me as a dress
but it was honestly a little bigger I
think I could have got away with a large
because I'm just like so petite these
days and then we have the ugly quote on
Christmas sweaters Hanukkah sweaters
that aren't so ugly yeah we are making
holiday sweaters for Jewish people too
yes so those are the same sizing as this
sweatshirt I had a large and those but I
actually would have preferred those more
fitted so when I get my next shipment
I'm gonna do small so I could wear it
with pants question in the YouTube about
shipping if you buy in the US today you
will 100% receive it by Christmas Oh
100% orders will start being shipped out
today Sarah place today the earlier
order comes in the faster it will be she
these are not made to order we ordered a
limited stock it's a big amount so it's
not that limited so items will
definitely sell out so I suggest being
on at 1 p.m. Eastern Time but you will
have ample opportunity to get what you
want if you're on time yes so very very
exciting we can't wait to see you at
1:00 p.m. make sure to check out the
Mauritshuis Instagram to see everything
that's on sale and in addition to like
holiday winter stuff we are bringing
back some of our alternative rich some
of the mid apparel that og toasters have
but it came out like a year ago so if
you didn't know us then I'm so sorry the
supreme logo where we had the toaster
logo that's available in a sweatshirt
and a t-shirt now and the sweatshirt is
actually new it's a hooded sweatshirt
yep so [ __ ] cute then we have our Old
English long-sleeve by the way when i
zoom in greets so many people wear those
so [ __ ] cute these are unisex sizing
so they're already like a little baggy
those are the best ones to wear as a
dress then we have the morning toast
racer long-sleeve such a great one um so
there's so much for you to get for
yourself for other people just deck the
halls' you guys because it is the
[ __ ] season Kalyn Petrelli can
you purchase the sweatpants separately
from the crop yes these are sold
separately so if you just want the
sweatpants or you just want the
sweatshirt you are more than able to do
that yeah I
that's gonna be my new travel outfit for
everything I've been dying for a TMT
like track suit so we have to make one
yeah we also are going to make a TMT
track suit no but like to me this is a
track suit yeah but also like one with
the zipper yeah but to me it's the same
thing we're inspired by Geoffrey Oh Olli
always I find myself being inspired by
Geoffrey star in my everyday life every
day every way we also have onesies and
we have brooms and I just want to say
something about the rooms because I know
that like of course we're just gonna say
glowing things about everything that we
make but that robe is the softest most
delicious most plush robe I've ever worn
in my life and now that I think about it
I don't think I've ever splurged on a
robe for myself like when I want a
really cozy one sometimes also steals
acts but all my groups are like kind of
thin and matte this robe is just like a
delicious hug and I it's one size fits
all and it really fits all I need to
give them as your shout out because I
picked up that robe and they were like
it's one size fits all I'm like no it's
one size fits everyone except for me and
it fit me very well and I think if I was
heavier I would have able to fit me also
it had much room to grow well yeah all
of our husbands were wearing it you know
if it's me if it's them if it's a it
really fits everyone so that's just a
knock it out of the park yeah it's a
great it's a great option just lay
around year round and we have the
onesies which are so freakin cute and
those I wore size small in that too just
because I am really short so I didn't
need all that extra materials yeah for
my sizing I pretty much more large for
everything unless I wanted it oversized
and then I wore an extra large yeah also
the pony does not come with the
sweatshirt unfortunately maybe we'll
work on that for next year um anything
else oh we have a mug though sling my
way through the holidays with the TMT
logo it's very cute and it's a big
[ __ ] mug like it's not standard mug
size I would say it's XL mug you could
get maybe like two coffees in there it's
really really cute and toasty and then
we have stockings which were like the
first and most obvious thing we want to
do for the holidays we're like we're
doing a holiday job where our pink
stockings yeah and they're really well
done honestly like the stitching is
stunning they have a hook so you can
hang them on your mantle I don't really
know what I'm gonna do with mine seeing
as how I don't have a mantle and I'm
Jewish but I'm gonna figure something
out
yeah I by the way I'm size five I am
height five one and I wear a small in
the onesie someone saying they're super
tall will the ones he's fit yes because
they don't have the toe part so even if
you're 6 foot tall like it's a it's a
cropped ankle yeah crops but like
fitting
so we'll just look like a pant on you
maybe a Capri onesie if you like seven
foot it's really premium stuff I hope
everyone can go what they want reminder
the website is shop morning toast calm
and it's going live at 1:00 p.m. Eastern
Time so that's 10 a.m. in LA and then if
you're in other time zones just please
figure it out yourself I just I don't
understand time zones and I don't think
I ever well yeah so we moved it to one
so that everyone could have a fair
chance and you don't have to watch in a
slideshow obviously but if you are hey
what's good can't wait to see you later
what's good counts what's good counts
um this is the like second day in a row
where I smell cigarettes to smell
cigarettes no I don't maybe oh just
becoming he does okay I'm becoming used
to it because of my little sister it's
the ghost of snitches has passed yeah
and someone is lighten up but it's nice
because we really miss her every day
here but now when we smell her a little
cigarettes I always think about Carrie
Bradshaw Cathy and her cigarettes the
book of it the children's book she
wanted to write oh yeah Cathy on our
magic series yeah that's counselor and
her magic cigarettes by the way like it
stinks interesting it's not so bad well
we have a great show for you today it's
gonna be a hell of a toasty day so 1:00
p.m. Eastern Time shot morning coats are
calm don't worry we will remind you
constantly throughout the show and
without further ado do you think that at
this time hmm yes I want to say yes I'm
a positive person I try and look out you
know with a glass-half-full kind of
perspective so yeah I would say it's
time it's time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and yeah I'm not gonna disagree
with you on that it's definitely that
sounds right it's definitely definitely
borderline true that it's time but I
would almost be like remiss I I think I
might even be devastated or even
heartbroken I think if I didn't let
everyone know that Shea's a very special
day because our episode is brought to
you by amazon's original the marvelous
miss may so it is a winner of 16 emmy
and three Golden Globes amazon's
original the marvelous miss hazal
returns for an eagerly awaited new
season on today December 6
hailed as one of the best shows on the
small screen of any genre by deadline
this season takes a mijin Suzy on a
comedy tour throughout the u.s.
sounds like the dirty jeans tour with
stops in Miami Las Vegas n la filled
with original music sweeping dance
numbers and museum were worthy costumes
and some of the most lush production
design on TV the series award-winning
cast includes Rachel Brosnahan a
sporting you know she's a sneaky nose
brown nose over the hidden agenda Tony
Shalhoub
Jane Lynch the hardest-working working
woman in Hollywood and more alongside
new and notable guest stars like
sterling K Brown its 1960 man time to
see why this beloved series is a modern
marvel watch the new season of the
marvelous mrs. Mazal December 6 only on
Amazon Prime video you can start
streaming it today the third season
probably gonna win all the Oscars
Grammys Golden Globes attic on again so
make sure you're not missing out
marvelous mates I'll head over to Amazon
I'm so excited to have something to
watch this is the season where I just
like stay in bed and binge watch TV
choose the suit is the season so I can't
wait to watch at all so today's just a
day of like premium content because
marvelousness nasals out morning toast
question is out and Taylor Swift's new
Christmas song which is not a story so I
just want to touch on it really quick
sure because we were sitting here
listening to it and this is such a
[ __ ] balk and then Claudia told me
that she wrote it two days ago right
who's Jackie was like this music video
is like a little like whatever and I'm
like [ __ ] she only had 48 hours and
Jackie's like what do you mean am i
Sheila D wrote the song two days I don't
like put together this like iMovie thing
and got in the studio and recorded it in
two days because she didn't wanna wait a
whole year to have to release it again
which I totally appreciate I would have
lived for like a very glamorous like
music video but like we said hopefully
directed by Hannah Lux Davis the hardest
working woman in the music video
industry 100% like a cheesy Christmas
like Kacey Musgraves Christmas special
by or even did you see Katy Perry
released an original Christmas song that
nobody cared about but she released a
music video that was like a really
[ __ ] premio if anyone could yes she
was like sitting at a big eggnog glass I
did see that Katy Perry released a
Christmas song but I did not hear know
who did know that not happening nobody I
think she also released it like
somewhere it's titled
it's like something they thought yeah
that's no wonder why nobody heard it but
in the music video it's like very
glamorous very Candy Cane Lane she's
sitting in like a huge glass of eggnog
Christmas tree farm is very Candy Cane
Lane like eight literally I couldn't
watch the video with it because it was
bringing me down and I was just like I
just want to be like fist pump yeah with
a cup of eggnog
well it's so cute she knows she did grow
up on a Christmas tree from yes so the
song is really cute it's really great I
just love getting more premium content
from Taylor like anything she wants to
release like my legs are open and I'm
ready to receive
yes I I'm happy for you I'm happy for me
imma add it to the Jackie hohoho
playlist whoa
and it's the great thing it's a great
thing to listen to as you shop your
morning toast winter collection merch
exactly a
okay our first story and a little bit of
hosting news no I found to be quite
interesante I found it to be quite of a
letdown
oh but its interests aunt that it was a
letdown
yeah it's disappointingly interesante
enews has finally named their co-hosts
for their New York Morning Show version
of enews cuz it was weird that they
announced that they were moving to New
York and was gonna be a morning show
this whole big thing and no co-host but
we knew that Giuliana and Jason we're
not coming so they have named Liliana
Vasquez and Scott Tweedy as hosts of the
morning show so um there's also there's
two shows that there he news and pop of
the morning great name okay so it's like
you made this huge announcement you're
moving your studios to New York you're
launching two new shows like you made it
such a big deal and for two shows you
hired two people so it's two separate
shows with the same tube co-host I don't
understand that sounds like one long
show this seems you co-hosts that had
less than hundred thousand Instagram
followers well so a lot of the toasters
no Liliana Vasquez I believe she does
some fashion segments on the Today Show
so she has qualified I'm sure and people
that seem to like her she's just like
lesser known so I'm honestly I'm not mad
at the choice and she's also very cute
like I wouldn't mind waking up and
seeing her face I don't know the dude
I'm just like I can't get over this
Australian I think I looked at his
Instagram I just can't get over like the
sheer volume it's like give two hours of
content with the same two people I don't
I literally don't understand they must
be incredible but what's the point in
making two separate shows if you're
gonna have the same two co-hosts for
both shows that's just one long shot
well from what I understood pop of the
morning is um like more of a panel show
some maybe it's the two of them and some
other people okay
maybe it's just like a lot for us to
digest to brand new people you know like
I feel like with the stars that I love
it II like Justin and Morgan like they
started with one thing and then they
started to do more and then daily pop
went to five days and then she did
nightly pop then Justin did just the sip
like they grow they don't you don't just
get two hours a day five days a week
like we don't know you yet yeah that I
totally good I feel like they have so
much talent at me like Aaron Lim who
likes the hardest working woman and now
she's on e news and now she does red
carpet that's how it starts and ro so
curious it's like y know
from La wanted to move to New York and
like helm this opportunity well are they
were they not offered when we went to LA
and like we were just like being LA
students for the week like people who
live there like [ __ ] loved it and I
don't think e news like pays people that
well or even treats them that well that
they would want to you know uproot their
lives but the people who live there
yes they like it but they're also like
hustling and they want to be successful
and it's like I feel like any of them
could have raised their hand and been
like I'll go to New York and like then
you are on you know a huge show it's
also kind of like being like a
correspondent for a show in LA that has
like 12 other people on rotation it is
scary though to like pick up and change
your life for like a brand new show that
has absolutely no proof of that they
might use not a brand new show no but
then this whole concept isn't like you
they either might cancel the show or
like you know in the beginning of a new
show they rotate people out really
quickly like just to see what works if
it doesn't work and then they finally
find there's like you pick up your whole
life and then they don't rotate people
quickly they don't change things up it's
like you get like four Busy Philipps for
example like a from the get-go it wasn't
working and like they just try to make
that work they chucked in jobs yeah they
never were like flexible oh and you know
what that reminds me of um a little late
with Lilly Singh we've never spoken
about it on this show yeah and you just
sent me a YouTube video that was like
someone really like critiquing her like
super hardcore and well he did raise
some interesting points I did think he
was a little mean um but we never really
spoke I haven't heard anything about it
and I don't know I I went to go search
in the morning tube because she's a
youtuber at her core and I want to see
what her fans like we're saying about
her and there wasn't chatter about it
I've heard like nothing I only heard
from that video I honestly didn't
realize the show had premiered yet let
alone premiered in September I thought
the video was well done he made some
really great points and like as a
digital person I was just like writing
everything down for myself
yeah like if we ever got the TV show
like what not to do yeah um but I think
the fact that we haven't heard anything
about it is campy tells you everything
that you need to know yeah it's also
like super late like I'm never watching
TV at 1:30 like I'm usually in bed like
trying to go to sleep by then yeah
absolute ending like I have at that time
yeah and I think the most interesting
thing that video pointed out was that
like she's shot to success just because
her content is really catered towards
young kids so it's like what kid is
watching late
TV at 1:30 like maybe they're up for
Jimmy Fallon really probably not maybe
but not yeah well this is a little very
interesting they'll be up for the
morning show I mean you know this is
just like we've been doing the morning
show over here at the morning toasts for
two years now so like welcome to the
category yeah I mean obviously like like
I said you know I have a problem when it
comes to like raging jealousy but
something about this like if they had
offered you the job would you have taken
it this job if they offered us the job
yeah yeah yeah yeah look and you would
give up the toast like um no I think
they would we would like turn the toast
into Joe's podcast so like just yeah
they would just like acquire the chosen
then the trust would be on TV no but
like if they wanted us to help me news
in the mornings and that's what we do
here and it's not that big of a
difference I think that that would be
mass success for like it would be able
work yeah I think it would be great
centered but only if they took us
together yeah of course I don't want to
work with Scott Tweety no me neither no
offense but Louisiana Vasquez seems cool
yeah she's definitely honest any vibes
no but like um no both are nothing yeah
no but no one asked yeah oh that's true
okay are you ready for our next story
am I ready for our next story should be
like you're ready I think I am and you
know what I would actually love sipping
for coffee is that an option you know I
made it today and I was like oh
Claudia's actually gonna want like like
this and I'll tell you it has a little
bit more sugar than I usually put in ooh
then you know I'm gonna like it it's
pretty good it's as good as coffee yes
it's as good as coffee gets you know
what did you ever find like you're
drinking a beverage whether it's an iced
coffee or just like any beverage with
ice and like the ice isn't working mmm
yes only with the die coke though your
coffees like not cold yes it is like to
the taste it's his room temp I'm sorry
I'm sorry to disappoint you you know I'm
my writer it says I can only drink non
room temp so I'm out of here I quit okay
Nicole Snooki Polizzi has announced
she's retiring from Jersey Shore family
vacation what yep she is out wait this
is such breaking news news she announced
it on her podcast it's happening with
Snooki and Joey she said there's reasons
why I've come to this decision in
today's episode it's definitely a hard
decision okay you guys I love you so
much
don't hate me for my decision but I have
to do what's best for me at the moment
and I am retiring from Jersey Shore I am
NOT coming back to Jersey Shore family
vacation for a season four if there is
one and there's a lot of reasons why but
the main reason is really I'm just like
I just can't do it anymore
I hate being away from the kids I don't
like partying three days in a row it's
just not my life anymore and I want to
be home with the kids you know like I
don't mind to here and they're going to
dinner or whatever but it's just really
hard on me to leave the kids in film a
show yeah I hear you loud and clear I
hear you loud and clear
I feel like Jersey Shore coming back was
so great like for you know as an idea
but in terms of execution the fact that
they all live in different parts of the
country they like have to all take a
vacation together like that's not
feasible anymore like Deena and Angelina
just got married like everyone's lives
are changing not so much on the guys but
even Ronnie like he has a kid now yeah
Mike is married like they're gonna start
having kids soon like it's not a perfect
formula like and it honestly maybe would
be able to continue if they all lived
like on the Jersey Shore like something
with the Jersey Shore like what we're
used to is like them partying and being
funny and drinking and like you just
can't do that at a certain point and I
think is eclis yeah and I think it's
great that like she gave us three more
seasons um
but you could feel like the sadness that
they it's yours
no but also they just want to be home
they miss their kids yeah and they have
to go here and act like they're 21 again
yeah and to be honest like I I feel
really strongly that flora batma Shore
is filling the gap that Jersey Shore
left in our hearts and like I'm feeling
really fulfilled like I have recently
gotten back on the floor batma Shore
train and it's literally such a
phenomenal show like I watched a new
episode last night like those kids are
working overtime and you know what I
follow some of them on Instagram I
follow Amy and Nilsa and literally like
they don't stop when they're off the air
like they are drinking so much Nilson
literally passed out at her hallway last
night like that's like who they are to
the court like they drink that much
whether they're on camera or off and
they're still in that phase of their
lives and like it's perfect for them and
I feel like they should stop trying to
make Jersey Shore something that it's
not 100% there are a lot of people out
there who are willing to like drink
siesta key for days on end we didn't
report on that yesterday because I knew
been like wouldn't care or like know
what I'm talking about but Robbie Hayes
is joining the third season of siesta
Kay that is wild and I believe we're
gonna have some siesta key guests next
week which is very exciting that's so
crazy that he's joining the cast on
it's gonna be amazing no one like I knew
that they were filming and I know that
she was dating Robbie I thought he would
that he make a cameo and it never I
don't know why I was like so surprised
by this news but like I very easily
could have put it together no it's so
surprising
it's shocking like Jo Jo Fletcher must
be just like rolling her eyes to the
back of her head a hundred percent it's
crazy but they're all they're all so not
together anymore Juliet Andrade yeah I
wonder if he's a mainstay on the show
but he doesn't mean like living si esta
queso it's so knowing him he would move
yeah he's already moved yeah I'm really
proud of Snookie
I think this is so the right decision
for her and her family and I'm sure it
was so difficult not only to like say no
to that paycheck and whatnot but I'm
sure her cast members like this Jersey
Shore is not the Jersey Shore with me
and now that she's saying no I wouldn't
be surprised if there is no season four
and she's taking that away from all of
them but like she she has to put her
family first and she is and I think it's
like it's so crazy how Snooki has become
like the face of like reality TV culture
and like being crazy and you know she's
like the butt of every joke but when it
comes down to it she has her head on
straight yeah and I think that this is
so the move I think it is - I mean
honestly I respect it so much like I
can't say that I would have been as
strong if like but you just do with the
money what the money tells you and I am
sure that they are paid being paid
handsomely I remember at the peak of
their Jersey Shore success the the og
cast mates were making like upwards of a
million dollars in episode so they were
doing really well and I think that when
that was over like a lot of them kind of
had like a fall from grace and they
didn't really know what to do for a long
period of time and then they all kind of
got their lives together and started
having normal lives but then the
opportunity for the show to come back
like obviously you want to chase that
high again and while the money I think
is great I don't think it's ever really
gonna be the same like things change
people grow up and I think they need to
like move on from trying to capture like
the magic yeah and she has a lot going
on she has a podcast like you need to
find sustainable sources of income if
you're gonna ever like really live a
happy life and settle down yeah agreed
and I think it's best for everyone in
the cast that this happens and I'm like
living for her announcing it on her
podcast like we love an entrepreneurial
spirit and we love it I mean love each
other we do oh my god I have been
watching joey camasta Instagram stories
religiously like him cooking him cooking
his games by the way he needs I mean
just chew an appropriator like he really
needs a cooking show like I have never
watched someone's cooking Instagram
stories from start to finish like so
automatically like he is so [ __ ]
funny like he's a true talent it's too
bad the Food Network is like so you know
PC because I think he would be a star
yeah he is a star he made shrimp scampi
the other night no spaghetti because
he's not even carbs it was just so funny
that's so funny
okay ready for our next two more reality
TV news because Khloe Kardashian has
taken to Instagram oh my god I know I
know Jackie I knew when I chose this
story that you wouldn't want to hear it
we Chyna these mother [ __ ] like I
love Khloe so much and Jordan has
responded oh okay fine I didn't say that
I didn't say okay so Khloe took to her
Instagram and also she said something
that was just like making me think of
Real Housewives and like how everyone
needs to like feel this way in their
lives where she was like if someone
hurts me like boyfriend colleague
co-worker
you know friend frenemy like I can move
on like I forgive you I really just I
really wish you the best but it just
means we don't have to have anything to
do with each other but it really feels
like from the bottom of her heart like
she hasn't she like dedicates her life
to like being positive yeah and not
heart like holding on to negativity but
just cool cuz I think like everyone just
like holds a grudge yes and talk [ __ ]
and like wishes ill for everyone else I
definitely do that occasionally release
a really nice statement because I guess
she was getting some flack from the
episode because it looked like she was
forgiving Tristan but like why can't you
forget I'm Jordan right and I'm sorry I
think it's different but okay I he'll
hold higher expectations for women I
know that's bad cuz we're all equal it's
different because trans in Tristan is
intrinsically a part of her life
forevermore run the form of True Jackson
VP so she has to find a way to make it
work like yeah and goodbye like their
co-parents now like for the sake of true
they just gotta get their [ __ ] together
right and London is irrelevant it's not
like Jordans like sending text messages
and apologies and diamond bracelets yeah
right and maybe if she was like things
would be different
maybe so anyway Jordan reposted a quote
her Instagram stories that read someone
somewhere is still discussing the old
you because they don't have access to
the new you
she then tweeted not every quote that is
posted as a sub or a clap back Chloe or
Jordan posted that Jordan posted that
like and people no one was even talking
about Jordan in the episode no but in
Khloe's statement oh this was after oh
this is her response yes oh after Chloe
statements saying that she forgives them
both yes
just because you've moved on Jordan
doesn't mean other people still are like
my Magette tweeted that that quote had
nothing to do
Chloe she said I deal with a lot of
different [ __ ] daily it's all love only
positive vibrations loss logical liza
minnelli
are we calling vibes vibrations now oh
is that what you men yeah okay I mean
this whole situation is so weird because
I didn't really see any flack that Chloe
was getting and I didn't think that her
releasing a statement wasn't necessarily
like necessary but she did and obviously
open the floodgates and then Jordan felt
the need to respond and then like I even
people like her like responds like in a
subtle way and they're like it's not
about this like it obviously is no one
was talking about you bruh guard'll
Aslam of that like one certain issue
right right yeah drama drama but
everyone seems to be doing well I just
hope this doesn't like spill into the
next season of Kardashians like I'm so
over this storyline or this storyline
like even with the bracelet stuff this
week look I just didn't care yeah oh my
god breaking news oh my god no oh my god
I'm literally so upset why Leonard
Goldberg the legendary Network executive
and film television producer behind
Charlie's Angels who's also it doesn't
say this in his thing on Hollywood he's
the creator of Blue Bloods he has died
it's like the age of 85 oh my god I'm
heartbroken at the end of every
bluebloods episodes it says created by
Leonard Goldberg
I feel like Leonard Goldberg is
responsible for like such happiness and
joy and like Family Values in my life
I'm so upset and he sounds like he's
Jewish like just you know we're flashing
about my friend Josh Lima also The
Simpsons okay but like more importantly
blue blood for you yes oh my gosh heart
breaking breaking news from The
Hollywood Reporter well it's sad but you
know a man dying at 85 sounds like he
was a very accomplished man it's a life
it's all love but I'm still it's all of
the show is never gonna be the same oh
my god I'm like literary tell Michelle
Bao its memory people I see may his
memory be blessing I mean the mourners
his eyen whatever they say but um I'm
really upset well I'm sorry I didn't
expect that this morning no I mean we
were on such like a holiday hi it hits
you hard
I'm sorry continue okay I ready for our
next story no you're not you want to
still talk about Chloe Tristan and
Jordan oh I really actually want to talk
about your hair can you give me a little
bit more in depth about what's going on
what do you mean well that's obviously
not your hair right it's a ponytail
extension how is it wrapped around your
hair like that
that's how ponytail extensions work they
come with a piece that wraps around
and then where's your real hair it's in
the pony that's so cool that you can't
really see it no I can't see it at all
that's awesome because like usually if I
had a professional do it it would be
like super snatch but you know me I just
like have one comb and hairspray yeah
and I try to make it work and your
function of beauty of course of course
beauty isn't one size fits all so why
should our hair scarib a function of
beauty individually formulates each and
every one of its products based on your
unique hair type pair goals and
aesthetic preferences so that your hair
gets exactly what it needs to look and
feel its best most drugstore brands only
address a single hair concern like
volume eyes or color protect and
ultimately they make you choose between
the two
but with function of beauty you can
choose up to five hair goals to add to
the formulation that means you no longer
have to sacrifice your hair goals just
because your shampoo said so so function
of beauty is a completely customized
hair and conditioner brand they
formulate every bottle based on your
hair type your hair goals and your
aesthetic preferences you can choose
between nine different colors including
dye free and seven unique fragrances
including a fragrance free option the
products are so personalized or mainly
desi is even printed on the bottle which
I love because the embed doesn't touch
it it's like [ __ ] is mine
also I've tried many different hair
shampoo and conditioners in my time and
I'll pay a lot of money for like an
expensive ass bottle of shampoo and it's
tiny
yeah the function of beauty's portions
are very reasonable there are huge jugs
just like me and I really appreciate the
size it's like something that not enough
people talk about also there's nothing
fancier than like monogrammed stuff and
stuff with your name on it function of
beauty never uses sulfates parabens
flatulates if you can't pronounce it it
shouldn't be in your haircare they don't
use any harmful ingredients in any of
their products plus they are 100% vegan
and cruelty free we love they now offer
three customized treatments to give us
an added boost to your hair goals so you
can get a hair mask for deep hydration
which is great for the winter months I
did one of their hair masks just a few
days ago they also offer a hair serum to
DeFries and increase shine which is very
important Chris Appleton taught us that
they also now offer an ultra lightweight
leave-in conditioner to help you smooth
hydrate and protect your hair I love to
sleep in a leave-in conditioner if you
guys want to receive 20% off your first
shampoo and conditioner set to redeem
head over to function of beauty calm /
toast take their hair quiz we love a
quiz makes us feel seen they shipped to
the US and many locations worldwide if
you go to function of beauty calm /
toast
get 20% off your custom formula we think
you'll really enjoy me
be a nice holiday gift for the hair
freakin in your family or your close
circle of friends function of beauty
calm / toast sign on get shiny healthy
beautiful hair in beautiful bottles that
have your name on it that your husband
won't touch sign on shine on by the way
I was gonna say that that's so crazy
that you said that but then I thought
made me like you wouldn't like it and
like it would make me redo it or
something
sign on I ever made me redo I don't know
but I was just like the only
self-conscious better but I want you to
know like I had the same thought process
okay cool yes sign on Shawna are you
ready for our next story because it's a
little bit of business by the way I have
to say I was able to watch the show
yesterday and a few things had me crying
first of all been pretending like he
knew what was gonna happen for business
though and then his arms just became
like chicken arms it was so funny and
secondly Oh daddy foreskin sandy
foreskin
by the way been kept doing that in the
car on the way to the Brits and I was
like what are you doing it's so funny
and I feel like it was funnier too like
if I was sitting here and he was doing
it I wouldn't have found it as funny but
literally what happens at a bris no cuz
it's so quiet everyone like doesn't
really know what's happening cuz you
can't see the baby but then all of a
sudden you hear the snip and you're the
baby like there's a beat Wow and it's
like oh it's over now we eat it's so
funny ever been to a bris like been
really nailed like the real vibe you
know
that's so funny okay a little bit of
business um that I think it's just gonna
be pertinent to everyone's situation
Rent the Runway has partnered with W
hotels so you can now pack lighter huh
rental Rama is hoping me make packing
for your vacation a little less painful
the clothing and accessories rental
services teamed up with Marriott
internationals W Hotels brand to launch
a one-of-a-kind rental experience at
four locations Aspen South Beach DC and
Hollywood so those are good locations
starting Thursday visitors to these
hotels will have the option upon arrival
to pay a $69 fee and pick four styles
from rent the runways curated selection
to wear during their stay the clothing
will take into account the climate and
surrounding activities like skiing or
pool Rent the Runway will ship the items
to W hotels where they will be delivered
to one's room at checkout the clothes
can be left behind in the row I mean as
someone who has almost on every trip
she's ever taken had like a revolver an
ASUS order sent
to my hotel just in case I didn't have
enough options like this is something
that definitely I feel is cater towards
me ya know this is pretty genius
especially when it comes to skiing trips
and this was something they swim hard to
pack that stuff yeah on Shark Tank this
week there was a genius company that's
pretty much like Rent the Runway for ski
kits like you order everything they sent
it to your destination it's the clothes
it's the gloves it's the goggles because
it's annoying to pack that stuff and
it's expensive especially if you're not
like an avid skier so I thought it was a
great idea and obviously run through
runway I watched Shark Tank this week
and they just scooped that right up
partnering with Aspen it's a really good
idea this is a great idea so cool for
everyone and I know we have so many
toasters who'd around the runway we love
run throw away and it's like a bigger
sponsored story by the way I just I
thought it was really cool if it's like
a bigger thing like obviously this
doesn't really help anyone right now
like with the four locations it's
obviously just a test but if it becomes
like an integrated thing and like all
SPG properties like that would be crazy
yeah also but right now it's just W
hotels and hopefully they'll expand into
all W hotels but even right now like the
people who stay at W Hart House are the
people who use runs around ya know it's
very good and like in Miami like you
know you need multiple looks like you're
hitting the sand bar or you're hitting
Bagatelle and then it's like I don't
want to take it home with me to then no
oh my god at the door you're like
literally just putting it in that
garment bag is just like just dropping
it as premium this is actually a great
[ __ ] idea yeah I feel bad for that
shark tank company cuz they just lost
their clients in Aspen yeah but um I'm
still using I would use both I watched
Shark Tank last night and I'm definitely
looking at the episodes now with a much
more critical lens I do think that like
sometimes people come into the tank and
are just the Sharks are just like in a
bad mood and they're really rude for
like literally no reason this guy came
in he only had proto today there's no
shark accountability you know right and
there's no consistency so here's what
bothered me this guy came in he had a
prototype he was really an inventor he
wasn't a businessman like honestly I
didn't think the product was that stupid
you know how like when you're potty
training a kid you get that like cushy
small toilet seat that goes inside so
the kid doesn't fall through the toilet
this guy made a specific type of toilet
seat that's can be both sizes adult and
child you like flip it up you flip the
lid so they you don't stake it out and
put it off yes which is like a brand new
toilet seat for your toilet and it's
good for your kid and for you and it was
like not that dumb it didn't really like
solve a problem but it was like an
interesting concept they were
so rude to him oh my god like me funny
thing yeah he was an older gentleman
they were like hysterically laughing at
him and it was just like they were so
rude and they were like Robert said the
craziest thing he said you know there's
a line with you know pitching sales and
you just cross it like you're selling me
too much so the guy was too much of a
Salesman like they were so rude and then
this next people came in and they were
so accommodating like and it was the
dumbest company were they a little
younger but still not like millennial
age but they were three people who had
three full-time jobs and they [ __ ]
hate that god yeah bad you family while
you're pursuing your passion and they
had a full-time hobby okay they made a
company called milk and rookies so it
was brownie cookie combos and they were
delicious but it was like this girl
did on the kitchen or anything they get
orders and at night after work she fills
them and sends them they've made like
$12,000 it was really like a bit like a
bake sale like it was a lemonade stand
it was very much a hobby and I just they
came right after the toilet seat I who
got such disrespect when I honestly like
these people deserve the same amout of
disrespect like they didn't have a
business they barely had like a website
like it was just like like it just
depends on the Sharks mood they were so
rude to this guy and they're like so
nice to these three people who just came
in with their hobby I was like how do
they even get on Shark Tank yeah not
cool not cool I'm glad that you're
seeing this yeah it's like I love shark
tank I think it's an incredible show
it's taught me everything that I know
about business which is you know limited
obviously but there's sometimes like
just the rules aren't the same for
everyone yeah I feel like no one ever
calls them out because like they're
Sharky yeah and one girl called someone
out I remember she did the UM the
gourmet applesauce and it was like a
whole new category she ends up getting a
deal with Mark and she was a really
really smart woman who worked at News
Corp and she's like a very high paying
job and she didn't quit her job she said
no I'm hiring people and I'm working on
a part-time and they were all like
leaning on that as to why the reason
that they were out and she was like
honestly like I support my family and
like other members of my immediate
family like I can't just go quit my job
because you think that makes me more of
an entrepreneur when she comes back yeah
man that at the same mark human
respected her so much for clapping back
that he gave her a deal and honestly
I'll never forget that woman I don't
think or my applesauce company ever went
anywhere but I respected the hell out of
her for using some goddamn logic this
woman worked her whole life
climbing the corporate ladder to get to
in position at News Corp and she said
you can't work your whole life in half
and do something and then also have a
passion project no it's so incredibly
stupid and it's not like the business
was like failing because of it she hired
full-time staff like she was taking care
of her business yeah and business that
she learned from her other full-time job
that's what I'm saying I can't omission
that that sort of logic really pisses me
off
100% okay our fifth and final story is a
little art news because it's Art Basel
right now and I saw this story and I
just thought wow I can't wait to hear
what my sister Claudius is about the
banana yes yeah okay okay
a banana duct tape tulle wall sold for a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars at
Art Basel in Miami this week the work by
the Italian artist
Maurizio Cattelan who is Italian
Kimber's father titled Italian Kimber is
about to get a real nice yeah yeah it's
titled comedian but the gallery
representing Catalan says it's not a
prank and that every aspect was
carefully considered including the exact
placement of the banana on the wall
please the demand for the work was so
high they raised the price to one
hundred and fifty thousand for another
edition do they tell you who bought it
and what [ __ ] no I didn't see that do
you remember when bank sold to a
Frenchman French camper's father oh wow
competing do you remember in banks he
auctioned off like this huge piece of
art and then the second it got bought it
was retro actively shredded and that was
like part of the art that was funny um
I'm sorry this is so stupid and like I
fully understand that I'm not in the art
world I don't really understand art like
I never seen the Mona Lisa but I heard
she's super small but like I respect it
but like I still don't really [ __ ] at
it I'm like these enormous prices like
for literally like a cube but like I
just don't get it um
so having said that I don't get this
tenfold and I think this is so
incredibly stupid and like this makes a
mockery of art yeah this makes art like
the Mona Lisa is incredible like there's
so many there's so much art that like
Pete everyone can see and see why it's
worth stuff there's like abstract art
where you just don't understand it and
this is a farce this is a farce this is
fart which is shocking because I think
Art Basel actually like I've seen some
of the work that like gets put up there
and it's all like really cool
contemporary like [ __ ] like I might
actually hang in my apartment so now
it's like you're bordering on stupid and
then wearing where do during where you
cross the border where do you draw the
line in the art world and I'm not in the
art world I'm not a gallery a girl so
like I can't
speak on it how do you draw the line
between what is art and what is stupid
it's right here now we know and it's all
subjective so it's like I'm sure there
is someone out there obviously the
person who bought it who thinks this is
[ __ ] brilliant and what happens when
the banana rots rots you have a rotting
banana and then how do you transport it
you take it the duct tape off the wall
then you let any duct tape it and then
like what if it loses its stickiness
that's a really good point
oh my god like honestly French cambers
dad is shaking like such a [ __ ] who's
your favorite artist oh um my favorite
artist is I think mr. brainwash yeah I
love pop art I think my favorite artist
is probably I don't know he's French
doctor Theodore for Chapman oh I mean
it's his medical background that really
allows him to just bring like a certain
flair to he's got a certain zest for
life he really does and then also his
history like he brings a bit of like
Russian 18th century modern into his
artwork and also a contemporary American
value know he went through a lot as a
kid and I think that kind of troubles
him and he's like a he's a disturbed
kind of artist my favorite kind today I
think also because of his upbringing in
his childhood he didn't have much of a
childhood so his art allows him to like
explore the wonders of childlike
imagery yeah the imagery is so important
I he's at our puzzle right now and I
don't like taking the town mice he's the
toast of the time I was on the yacht
with Bella Hadid and Kendall Jenner like
he was just cropped out of a photo cuz
he's very private but like just the
stars are loving his work honestly I've
like never really wanted to go to art
basel if I like it probably like a lot
of traffic just like I hate certain like
cities that get super busy for like one
moment right especially Miami even when
it's quiet yeah but like watching Gigi
and Noah Bella and Kendall like it look
like they're having so much fun like I
wouldn't mind going like with them like
they get you know and I speak bus that
takes them everywhere and they look like
they're having a good time so I wouldn't
mind hanging out with them speaking of a
nice big bus it's time for a real
housewives recap let's start with Dallas
because look at bus it's time for a real
house let's recap brought to you by a
brand-new sponsor the serial school I
love a serious now that we're adults
adulting some childhood memories seem
out of reach
especially treats we used to enjoy so
true like why can't I just have a bowl
of cereal in the middle of the day
remember picking out your favorite
sugary cereal
for we were all told to avoid extra Cubs
but most sugar-free cereals are bland
dry and get soggy way too fast couldn't
agree more and the cereal milk doesn't
taste good either that was always the
best part that's all changing thanks to
the cereal school let they let you eat
like a kid again with delicious low-carb
sugar-free high-protein cereal it's all
the flavors you love cinnamon bun fruity
cocoa peanut butter and more low carbs
no guilt just fun delicious snacking
that won't blow your macros founded in
the early 2019 by business and life
partners Helen and Dylan we love a
couple the cereal school makes healthy
snacking fun convenient and most
importantly delicious delicious I have
been having this peanut butter flavor in
my house for like a few weeks now Ben is
obsessed them it's a great snack and
really like I am the type of person
where like smells and tastes immediately
transport me back to certain moments so
it's like you know whenever I smell
truffle I remember on of the time I
threw up on Montauk Highway um but when
I have these peanut butter things I
literally I'm immediately transported
back to us sitting in the morning at
like 7:00 a.m. all having cereal in our
little Teletubbies bowl like in our
kitchen growing up it's actually crazy
how much like I missed that no totally
and what's great about the cereal school
is one they're very keto cease and
friendly like super health no alien
grain lactose soy or sugar and they have
16 grams of protein for serving and the
way that they come it's they come in
almost like bags like bags of chips so
it's like one serving at a time you and
also people love to eat dry cereal so
like you could take the bag with you and
just eat the cereal out of the bag or
eat just one serving one bag poured into
a bowl with milk like there's it's so
versatile but also like made for people
on the go I think you can also actually
put milk in the bag oh my god yeah
single stuff packaging so you can mix
and match flavors to create your perfect
variety pack they are perfectly
portioned there's no guesswork or
tedious measuring it's great for kids on
the go but also adults there are only a
hundred calories per bag and it is keto
season approved
I love the peanut butter where they have
tons of other options if you want to try
it is a healthy and delicious snack that
fits perfectly with our nutritional
needs our listeners can get five dollars
off and free shipping when you go to the
cereal school comm slash toast the
cereal school is so confident that they
will offer a risk-free satisfaction
guarantee on all orders the only way to
get five dollars off and the free
shipping is to go to the cereal
school.com slash toast that's th e CER e
al SCH ool dot-com slash toast the
cereal school enjoy cereal like a kid
again
amazing also like if you have a kid and
they're taking the bus and they're
running late you can just give them a
bag of the cereal so that's so true bus
and the bus and maybe a few for the
other kids like the cool kids in the
back oh for sure that's a great way to
make friends
okay the Real Housewives of Dallas I am
incredibly shocked by this trip because
to to the to me it looks like they're
having the worst time like none of them
feel good like they can't get their
sleep schedule correct they're all
fighting like the treacherous four-hour
trip to the elephant sanctuary every
time they leave the hotel like they hate
where they go like and they're like it
just seems like the worst trip but they
keep talking about how they're having
such a great time I think they're all in
such good spirits because they're
delirious with the time difference and
this episode of Dallas and this episode
of New Jersey had a common thing where
it was just they were both incredible
incredible at this I agree and what made
them so great it's like every five
minutes the tides were changing I was on
someone different person's side
different people were fighting and I
felt a million different ways about it I
felt bad for one person then the next
one I'm like yo [ __ ] you yeah like it
was I really felt like and branding
Redmond was like narrating my experience
yeah the episode yeah I mean I couldn't
agree more about that bus like therefore
I cannot believe it took them four hours
to get that to that elephant sanctuary
and once they got there like it was so
sad but like oh my god and the fact I'm
not of them were really complaining was
shocking to me because like that just
seems like so not know they're all such
troopers they really want to do
everything everyone's on board
I mean Lance the only one who wanted to
go home at night which I also understand
like she's older than them and yeah it's
tiring
I'm tired um I just want to say like
Cameron Thailand Cameron is my favorite
Cameron and Loki Thailand Cameron who
like really wants to be friends with
Kerry Brittingham
I really like no I love everything about
her I love her looks her she's just
being like so she's always fun but she's
being extra fun extra funny and her
commentary her interviews are so funny
when she was with the whiteboard showing
what they were doing I felt like I was
there by the way it was also very
helpful cuz I knew exactly the three Sun
position that they were doing she said
like people are having a threesome on
stage I would have been like oh okay
sure but then when she was like boom
yeah like I got it I got a call that an
Eiffel Tower
cuz like yeah the two people on top yeah
okay also I think the best part of the
episode was when Leeanne got back in the
car after in sanctuary and was like
talking about how the animals are broken
and she knows what it's like to be
and he was like literally chess is like
we're about to start liking you again
like you have to go and make everything
worse and that's exactly how I felt cuz
I was on the inside and then like she
brings it back to herself and I Brandi
Redmond was the MVP of the episode
Cameron Westcott is the MVP of Thailand
yeah no but like when she got in the car
and her voice cracks and she starts to
cry like it's such a genuine crime like
normally you would believe it but it's
like really again like about you about
you and your childhood and it's just
like it's too much but also there's you
are able to like think something and you
could be like oh my god this this
affects me so much because I've been
through something and you can think that
to yourself but like there's a you don't
say it every time yeah you know agreed I
think that also another really
interesting part of the episode and how
Leanne really isn't digging her heels in
on this dress thing I think she's
actually being really mature about it
but when they were explaining it to
Kerry and she was like how would you
feel if I said you're Julia looks like
anal beads and then it actually turned
out that lanta and say it looked like
anal beads remember yeah but Leanne
didn't bring it to the table to say it
looks like a you know but they were so a
100% was so wrong and what bothers me
the most in life and in everything when
Kerry was talking to Cameron and she was
like well with Leon I just said that
this upsets me I would have said I'm
sorry first of all I hate that [ __ ] if
you had just said it like this like you
wouldn't you would have you would have
the same reaction it's an excuse and
then you would have said if you just did
it like this like I think that's such
horseshit
especially because like Leanne handled
it perfectly at the table like let it go
let it go let it go got up and left yeah
agreed
I'm like and I love Kerry and I love
Deandra and I'm so not on their side and
like Deandra means so defensive and
saying it's a joke it's a joke it's not
a joke it's AIT's something mean that
you wanted to do but you were and you
just want to use a joke to pretend that
it wasn't mean it was really [ __ ]
mean but it's still not enough for me to
like take glance at Lee Anne side
because she's got to stop with the
Mexican thing oh yes
what the [ __ ] is that it's the weirdest
thing what's crazy it's like obviously
when she's in Thailand she doesn't
realise that um it's not okay what's she
saying because in her commentary she
obviously knows and she's not using that
toy yes and now I'm like I haven't seen
that much on Twitter I haven't been
looking but like I think she's obviously
apologized for it and she knows now
why'd she say it's so many times many
times it's awful it's so Noreen and it
takes away completely from the fact that
like she was technically right yeah also
I don't know why she
so [ __ ] mad at Carrie Brittingham for
that ping-pong show thing like all the
women wanted she's oh yes
blaming Carrie and then Carrie left
because it was just cause Tiffany's been
talking about the ping-pong show since
Dallas since they were in their spa and
by the way like you're in Thailand
you're in the neighborhood and like this
is a thing that happens like oh and see
it and I'll go in this later I'm going
yeah they're being pelted with like
[ __ ] balls that's disgusting seems like
it's out my back but it's hilarious and
like exposure and in row you know I
totally agree Lee endeavour should have
went when she was at we are in a bad
part of town like relax grandma okay
look you have security you have security
you have a million people like they're
totally fine um definitely she's getting
jealous
Cameron honestly the group really hasn't
like loved Cameron these past three
season so it's made it easy for her to
become Leanne's best friend because Leon
is the only one is really truly accepted
her and loved her so she's loving being
Cameron's best friend yeah now it's like
everyone's really opening up like how
fun she is and of course she is and I
think traveling to foreign country is
like making everyone really open up to
Cameron and everyone's really like
wanting to hang out with her more and I
don't think that that makes LAN happy I
think she's kind of insecure in their
friendship and the way that LeAnn is
spinning it like Cameron just doesn't
know what she's going into like look
chap done
oh so Cameron like walking into like the
[ __ ] ball show like in her perfectly
white outfit literally looking like an
angel and I think all the women are
doing their own glam on this trip and
like yeah
Cameron's makeup even when she was here
like I'm [ __ ] shook to the core buyer
I'm like the bag joke she's getting
pelted but these bubbles in this dress
and like her white feather bag like it's
just so perfect it's hilarious also it's
like boiling that they don't think that
Leanne has apologised in ovarian time
and that they're gonna spend a lot of
time on communion they shouldn't like
she needs to be she needs to be account
accountable apologize really it's really
weird and it's really bad and now it's
like any time she gets mad at Carrie for
something that might be like stupid you
you have to question why she really is
like getting mad you know because yeah
also signs lead to like you know the
obvious but it's really [ __ ] weird
yeah I understand that she doesn't like
Harry and Carrie is like not letting
Leon get away with her usual [ __ ] um but
there's a way to say that without like
sobbing you're selling you're come on
Mexican you're all strong yeah I was
like
oh my god please stop Lea and then she
went up again in the cab like shut up
shut your mouth she's not so dumb
sometimes yeah um other than that great
episode I think we have one more episode
in Thailand and yeah
they're such oh I mean when Kat when
Cameron gets back to the hotel room and
Leon is like screaming I need to know
what what happened like you do not
scream at Cameron I can't even tell you
how she's like becoming one of my
favorite Housewives people read 30 sex
workers tonight so that's the yelling at
me no no and literally that's you guys
like actively chose to go do that right
it was very weird very weird okay New
Jersey New Jersey oh my god incredible
incredible lapis incredible episode I
mean we're on the same page right
Jennifer threw herself off the horse oh
there is Jackie like that and he watched
it twice I didn't see people saying it
on Twitter but like she literally like
leaned over I do know what you were
gonna say when we're on the same page
because I'm not on any certain page
either but 100% Jennifer like fake fell
off the horse she had full control she
like you can see her like putting her
momentum like into the water she's very
much like made-for-tv and she's enjoying
being a star and she won that's why I
think even when she said really Dolores
said last week that you guys aren't
friends like she knows what she's doing
she's an actress and I very much
appreciate and Stan but she's an actress
and she could have done a little better
job pretending to be the only reason why
I disagree is because that horse was
filled with poop water and she is like
okay by the way it wasn't filled with
poop water one of the horses pooped not
the shore no but that they do that every
day
they poop multiple times a day they poop
in the water all the time that is poop
water by the way like I always know like
when a group splits up one of them is
gonna have a good day one of them is
gonna have a bad day and like I always
take like if I was on the trip what
would I - and I would 100% have gone to
the beach and I always feel really good
about the fact knowing that like I
always choose the right thing yeah but I
think actually if I were there and I
never done that before
aside from the poop water if the water
wasn't like super poopy I would have
loved to ride horses on the beach it's
like you go go all the way on these
trips like try and use I like to try and
eat a little different than when I'm you
know I don't know these animals in
captivity so I probably would have gone
to the beach they don't look like
they're being abused they're literally
like being held on a tiny beach like
[ __ ] in their own homes and it's
just it doesn't look like very well kept
and I don't believe the animals should
be ever entertainment I don't sue me I
think I seemed okay to me it seemed okay
to me and I just can't lay on a beach
all day like
on a lounge chair I just can't no no
that's that looks nice Dolores like put
her cover-up on I really very much you
know related to her we need to talk
about Dolores yeah because I Stan like I
actually really like her I think she's
super smart
I do think more often than not she's on
the wrong side of history because she's
very loyal to Teresa but that's just who
I think she's like a loyal Italian
she'll tell you that a hundred times
upon meeting her and in that
conversation with Jackie she was being
so harsh and so mean but for some reason
I I can't get with Jackie like I don't
find her sympathetic at all yes so
overall I was really going back and
forth throughout the episode because I'm
the one hand I understand completely
what Dolores is saying like not everyone
is your cup of tea this girl's not my
cup of tea like that's that um but like
someone can be not your cup of tea and
then you just like move on and even
though it was brought up by Jennifer
like Dolores really digging in and like
just going out of her way to say I do
not like Lee you like you're not my cup
of tea
you're were cut from different class
like it was just it was mean and Jackie
kept saying like you're judging me or
judging me Jackie doesn't know anything
more she like harps on one word bullying
bullies like that's not the exact crime
that's being committed right and what
Dolores was doing is she was just being
mean and [ __ ] and like and it's so
weird because it's like I'm and
everyone's like you can't judge someone
else all we do all day as his judge but
like if you call someone else judgmental
it's like it's all of a sudden like they
can't do that when to Dolores she's just
speaking her mind I don't consider it a
great loss Dolores okay it was just like
Dolores was just being too mean in that
and no one was happier about the whole
dinner than Teresa oh for sure and I
think it was really like a Teresa
organized attack yep I know I agree and
that's my problem with Dolores is like
like I said she's always on the wrong
side of history but I just like like the
type of person she is like I get her
vibes she her and Jackie couldn't be
more different and they wouldn't
literally never be friends but you don't
want to say it's allowed like it was
really born out like pride in it like if
there was someone who I just like didn't
vibe with even though they had been
friendly so it's not like they haven't
like they're totally opposite like I
think Teresa and Jackie are totally
opposite yeah so it was just like it was
unnecessarily mean she was enjoying like
making Jackie feel bad and it was just
so really and making her feel left out
like we all said it even though no just
you said it Loras it was really
uncomfortable
yeah but I think also and like
everyone's been talking about like
Jackie and her eating habits um - horse
made a lot of comments this episode
about her own like body image like that
she was sad that she can't stop eating
blah blah blah she made it like three or
four times so it's obviously something
that's in her head on this trip yeah and
then she looks like Jackie who's still
regimented has so much self-control and
it's like yeah we'd hate that person too
it's like I just can't stop eating right
also it does turn out we spoke about
this last week and I didn't know for
sure so I don't want to speak on it if
it was true or not but Jackie did
actually end up tweeting that thing like
maybe if you watch what you eat you
wouldn't need to get liposuction every
day which was in a very obvious dig at
Jennifer who got a tummy tuck
after having five kids and then just got
a little bit more liposuction after she
lost 25 pounds um so she did tweet it
she did delete it and then she did like
put like a half-ass apology on Instagram
about it yeah and when you told me that
she said that I was like really shook
and it's so not okay and it's still not
okay but now I kind of understand like
she's backed into a corner now she's
just gonna come out swinging and she's
she's responding to everyone saying that
she watches what she eats too much you
know so like she's just throwing punches
and she's just trying to get out and
she's not my favorite person but I
really like her and the fact that like
she's so close with marginalists it like
tells me everything that I need to know
I think melissa in this episode was
meeting like such a good human being a
good friend yeah like on both sides she
did like was sitting around while people
were talking [ __ ] and like she defended
but not blindly she's in the tough spot
because she's in the room with all the
people who hate her friends yeah also
did you think that Margaret's comment
about jailbait was like an innocent
thing or she like very much meant it
like honestly I still don't even get it
like well because she was seen with the
21 year old no but like I understand no
I think anyone who said I want the 21
year old Margaret could have said that
too like it wasn't specific to Theresa I
don't think it was like a big deal at
all no me neither and honestly Theresa
didn't make it a huge deal so like I've
been grateful for that I just like have
such a hard time watching the show cuz
like obviously I love to read simply
she's always wrong yeah and she's like
she's not really like being a good
housewife anymore she's just kind of
like existing on the show and then like
lashing out at people who like wanna try
and like either be her friend like it's
just a really pressure there it's not a
fair game no because like if you that's
exactly what Jackie said it's like if
you have a problem with Theresa like she
slides you that's not valid because
she's had a hard year right and
dolorous saying that jackie harp sensing
more things more than other people like
that's this whole show no chewiness
actually harp some things more than
anyone what my problem is with Jackie
and which is what exactly what Dolores
point for last week is like she pretends
to be like this big lawyer like so tough
and it's like low-key she's always
crying about something like most people
could get over and but I think everyone
is always for some reason like ganging
up on her like on this trip everything
that she's being sensitive about it's
like very valid yeah I just like I don't
know what it is and maybe I'm just I
just don't like her like I'm like
Dolores like maybe I don't have a good
reason I just don't like her I
understand that like it's I'm on her
side here I think Dolores is is being
honest needed something lorises being a
bully they definition that was sure that
was bully do a Jackie tweeted something
it's like literally nobody Jackie I've
been hearing a lot of rumors that a lot
of people think I'm the richest
housewife in the franchise I wish haha
far from I just don't know I'm just the
type of person that knows money doesn't
equal happiness like it was just
literally like nobody thought that
nobody said that and then she's out here
tweeting like oh just remember I mean
being richest housewife you'll never
know yeah yeah yeah it was the weirdest
tweet that's so weird like literally
it's a meme nobody know and Jennifer's
obviously the richest in the franchise
in the new jersey yeah really I feel
like the Gorga's know I
Jennifer's husband's a plastic surgeon
oh that's true but I always do it based
on like how sizes she has the biggest
house does she yeah oh she is the and
the highlight of the episode was the men
oh thank you for bringing it up first of
all loved it and I like it wasn't weird
like it
Frankie Tania and Evan Goldschmidt are
like sitting here not knowing that like
Delores was quietly in Jamaica bullying
his wife right but also like it doesn't
really matter because everyone like
every week something changes so the men
don't need to get him out unless it's
like Danielle's table yeah I thought it
was so cute so funny I love Joe Benigno
like I love Joey Gorga like I thought
that was such a great like moment and
that doesn't really happen a lot like it
has to happen in the og like seasons of
Beverly Hills like with Mauricio and Ken
but like I'm not in a while I think last
season we had some like cute moments
between all between the Joe's yeah and I
think they saw that viewers really like
that so they had the guys get together
while the girls were away and like it
was just a slam dunk
I loved it love
like me Jenna I love that like he gets
along with the guys but he's still like
he's not like them you know more mature
he's mature and like he's not he doesn't
talk like them and like he's not as you
know open but like he still is a
personable
I thought he did such a good job of like
still coming off as a respectable doctor
who I would let like put me under
anesthesia but also like a cute funny
husband you know hundred percent like
the transformation of dr. Edith Eden
relationship from last season to this
season it's like he saw himself on TV he
was like I'm not that person and he is
working overtime to show America what
he's all about when to watch weapons
live this week with Jennifer he's had
the Oprah seats and he was on TV he was
just so cute and so funny and like a
rock star he's a rock star but he's
really doesn't want to take away from
the shine that his wife gets because she
like loves the spotlight and he like
loves that she loves it and I think he's
really seeing the value that she adds to
his business I can't imagine that they
haven't gotten so many more customers
and I go to dr. I to do an actor if I
lived in New Jersey he's so respectable
um and I just think like him was against
the whole thing in the beginning now
seeing a how happy it makes his wife and
be like how it actually is benefiting
his business and his family like I think
he's so on board and I like love him
know I love him and he got like hotter
to just from like being cute nice yeah I
just want to say like overall Jennifer
is an incredible addition she's a star
she's becoming one of my favorite
housewives and she might even be like I
mean I love Marja Melissa so it's tough
and I just need them to like be a
threesome I know but they don't like
Jennifer I know and it makes me sad no
they don't dislike her but like they
just stand Jackie and her and Jackie
you're always butting heads but there
are also friends yeah so weird it's so
weird I just love Jennifer I love what
she brings to the table and I even love
that she said Dolores doesn't consider
you a friend because otherwise we'd have
to wait till the reunion to hash it out
and by then I'd be over it so I
understand that she was being this [ __ ]
starter but like she just said what was
said yeah don't say it if you don't want
to come back agreed um other than that
the trip is like a little sad you know
it's just not like a great trip it was
around to me of the OSI trip it's like a
little low budget yet the ruling
situation it had to take on they had to
take a bus to go to the beach yeah oh my
god that made me very upset the [ __ ] was
they're not staying at a beachfront
hotel yeah it was the whole trip gave me
very budget cut vibe but something that
happened last
so and this episode is like in between I
like the drunk funny moments in the
fighting etcetera are having some really
deep conversations and last week when
they talked about like fertility and
gender disappointment I thought it was
so wonderful how they were all being so
open especially Theresa um I just
thought it was like such a beautiful
moment and then of course it went right
into a fight and it's like it's the end
of the day they're all just moms you
know I and usually the women of New
Jersey like aren't so open and I just
thought it was a really really nice
moment and then this week when Teresa
was talking about Joe and Melissa was
like I think they're gonna make an
example out of him it was yeah they were
going in and out of being shady deep
funny everything and that's what I want
for my Housewives right between Dallas
and New Jersey like the Shu episodes I
was riveted I watched him back-to-back I
did not go on my phone
once neither it was really good it was
so much better than I was saying like it
was really like real connections and
that's the thing it's like in New Jersey
like obviously you need to cycle in new
Housewives but so many of the women are
so like oh gee like they've been known
each other since high school like
Dolores like Teresa could have only had
that kind of conversation with only
Melissa and Dolores like family so while
like I loved having the new housewives
though they do limit that kind of
rapport because Teresa and Dolores would
never be comfortable having those types
of conversations you know yeah yeah so
all in all like a plus week from Bravo
yeah really really Rob oh really good
stuff you know what else is really good
stuff
morning toast winter collection dropping
at 1 o'clock p.m. eastern time that is
10:00 a.m. Pacific time the website is
shot morning toast com we have limited
stock it will ship immediately you
should be able to get what you want as
long as you're on at 1:00 p.m. there's
still some of the back-to-school items
in stock if you missed out on that we
are restocking old vintage items that
were highly requested like the Supreme
iam shirt that now also comes in a
hoodie we were getting the old school
English long-sleeve shirts and the
racing shirts right yep so just tons of
good stuff
make sure your check out shop morning
toast calm I think we're Nimmons for
your Christmas tree they're so cute and
like I can't have a Christmas tree
obviously but like oh my god I'm so
[ __ ] time - we have stockings and if
you need some stocking stuffers you can
get pop socket so you can get koozies
you can see a picture of your stockings
on the mantel Oh someone has to take it
for us because we're Jewish also your
ornaments on the Christmas tree like you
guys it's gonna be such premium stuff
when you order today you'll be getting
it within a matter of days and you can
just enjoy it all season long
there are some specific holiday things
but like I'll be wearing this all winter
long this toasty
Christmas light sweatshirt yeah no I'll
be wearing this jumpsuit for my life my
robe for the rest of my life the onesie
for the rest of my life because they're
they're great for the holidays but
they're not holidays if you want to see
more pictures of the items head over to
our Instagram the morning toast we
posted pretty much everything except the
mug what you got you have did for the
mug he's an oversight but you want to
see premium pictures of us in our
outfits how we size how we look and then
also the product shots you can get more
detail on our Instagram the morning
toast is obviously the username I
believe that's OB I already have for you
I'm just gonna run through some prices
really quickly yes the onesies are $65
each the beanies are $35 each the
beanies are so cute I was most expensive
I though the most expensive item is a
robe because it's just made out of
premium material and the robe will cost
you $75 everything's still under $100 we
try and keep it nicely priced for you
guys yes we really really do our ugly
Christmas sweaters are $50 there's two
that's a red and a blue a Christmas on
Hanukkah
yes Happy Hanukkah everyone the TMT
cropped hoodie is $60 and what else the
holiday mug is $25 how much are these
matching sweatpants with the cropped the
matching sweatpants with the cropped are
$60 okay
the Supreme iam toaster tea is $30 the
Supreme iam toaster hoodie is $60 so the
this toasty sweatshirt that I'm wearing
is $50 I think that's gonna be a
best-seller so I think goes up to 5x in
this sweatshirt and the - oh yes we got
a bunch we threw the Hanukkah and the
Christmas we heard your complaints the
khana all three of the post my top
sellers I'm gonna be going up to 5x so
you can get your size don't worry do not
fret and then the long-sleeve restocked
items the Old English white and black
long sleeves are $40 each so yeah
there's really something for everyone
and we can't wait to see you all wearing
it well we love you guys so much thank
you for the never-ending support we hope
you have an amazing weekend with your
new merch that hopefully will be
arriving early next week hope you can
get what you want thank you so much for
listening to the mourner
millennial Morning Show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
time YouTube so please if you're
watching this on YouTube subscribe give
this video a thumbs up leave a comment
we're also available as a podcast pretty
much anywhere podcasts can be found so
that's modified that's iTunes that's
stitcher that's public radio that's
iHeartRadio that's cast box wherever you
listen to podcast subscribe to us leave
a five star view about how stunning
smart beautiful and skinny be our mom
shot morning toast calm is the website
for merch I am headed to Rama
aurelio Rama casino in a really Ontario
today for a show tonight if you want to
come tickets are available girl no job
calm and I'll be in Tarrytown
Westchester tomorrow um I think Jackie
blog should be there right perhaps okay
it's gonna be surprised and it's uh
there's like very few tickets left so
check it out also just if you want to
come see me tickets available girl done
job back home shop morning toast comm
one o'clock p.m. Eastern Time we will
see you guys there if you really want
something get on it one o'clock just to
alleviate your pin and make sure that
you got it love you bye
you